Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
September 24th, 2012. What's going on?
How are you? How, how's your little
Monday doing? Where are you eat at work?
He's sitting in a cubicle. You're on
the treadmill. Did you call in sick?
Did you do that? Did you have the
right sound and your voice? Yeah. Hey,
it's Michael. Uh, I don't
know what happened, you know,
last night I wasn't feeling
so good and uh, you know,
you just fucking be here yourself going,
what am I doing? I can't just be like,
Hey, this is Michael. Listen, um, the job
is fucking sucking the soul out of me,
but I don't have any other
financial options. So, you know,
I'm going to keep working there, but
not today. How about that? All right.
Go Fuck Yourself.
We'll see on Tuesday.
That'd be great.
If you could just be that honest.
It's still somehow earn a living,
you know,
somehow fucking still be asked to come
to work the next day. Uh, Michael,
can you come in here a wee some
concerns about some of the insubordinate
comments that you made?
What does that word even fucking mean?
This insubordinate means independent
thoughts. Is that what it is?
Some of your thoughts that
are outside the green.
All the thoughts that we told you to have.
You're not having any more
and that that concerns us.
You're always a guy who was thinking,
um,
what we were telling you to think
in the past and suddenly you're not.
And that concerns us and that concerns us.
So just to let you know,
you just went from the yellow list over
to the blue list and the next list is
the red list and those people go first.
What's that? I'm talking
about FEMA camps. Yes I am.
Um,
that's something I looked up to reading
about those fucking lists that they have.
I wasn't a little, I wasn't fucking
reading about him. Did I read about him?
I just watched a couple of
youtube videos about it. You know,
it's funny about the fucking
new world order. You know,
what makes me chuckle about it
is it's completely on paper.
It's totally fucking necessary.
I've come full circle. I understand
why I'm going to be eliminated.
So if anybody in the fucking hood, a
cloaked hood or whatever, you know,
if you're listening in while you're
dripping fucking hot wax on a Goddamn
Maltese Falcon, whatever the fuck you
doing in your weird ass little ritual,
I don't need to be reeducated.
I get it.
Just get on with the killing,
you know,
that'd be the only guy going to a death
camp, like playing a banjo, you know,
with a folk tune called I get it.
Um, no, I seriously, I was
reading all this shit about,
you know how in the UN there finally
talking about the population problem and a
lot of people are coming up with this
shit where they're just like, look,
we got to get rid of 90% of
the population, you know,
and to do it in a way that like,
you know,
okay,
does it make every other fucking genocide?
Like look,
okay,
what am I trying to say here?
Okay.
The only way you can fucking do that.
What am I trying to fucking
say here? Jesus Christ. Okay.
So thanks. Go. All right.
If everybody just has
one kid from here on out,
we could get the population down to like
three and a half billion by 2075 but I,
but the problem is, is like most things,
we just treated it like a term paper.
It's too fucking late. So you got other
people like, oh no, we got to fucking,
you know.
Yeah,
you got the other people
there acting like,
you know the host of that hoarder show
or they're just like throw it all out.
It's all shit. Right. I think that
that's what they're going to do.
Okay.
So I guess if you want to survive,
what you have to do is you got to up what
you're bringing to the game, you know?
Cause if you're like me and you kind of
like the human equivalent to a stack of
newspapers with a dead cat underneath it,
you know, you, you're going to
bid a, you're going to be gout.
I'm going to be out the fucking window.
All right.
I wonder if they going to let
you choose how you want to die.
How would you do it?
Okay.
Yeah. What do I do? You know
what I would like? I'd like,
I would like to fucking be on some
sort of Bungee cord that goes fuck.
Instead of up and down, it goes
side to side and I just swing on it.
They bring me back. Oh, they got rob.
Oh giant sling shot and just get shot to
that giant TV at a cowboys game during
like a Monday night football game. You
know? No one that I'm going to die,
but I set it up like it's going to be
this stunt where I'm going to go over it,
you know?
And I just horrify some kids.
That'll be like my last thing is I bounced
off that turf right next to Tony Roma.
I'm sorry people.
I've been alone all fucking week.
This is the shit I'm thinking about.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
Everybody.
This is the uplifting MMP talking
about eliminating 90% of the people,
the world's population. As you sit
there eating a fucking eat Claire. Huh?
Who had one already who already had
a fucking eat Claire this week? Huh?
Who? I don't these, why Claire's,
who eats a fucking eclair?
You know what I mean?
[inaudible] fucking God damn.
TJ's in the middle of it. I mean,
if like it wasn't disgusting enough,
you got to get like a doughnut facial.
That's got to be like one of the,
you know,
like the low points when
you just have like total,
like just self hatred I
would think as a fat person.
If you just bought a dozen eclairs when
you're polishing off like the eighth or
ninth one, if you had a big
fuzzy beard, it's all in your,
and you look like you're in some
doughnut boot cocky movie. You just got,
he's got to be like, or what,
what happened? You know,
I used to climb trees.
I used to do cartwheels.
Um, I'm going back to La Tomorrow. Man.
I had a great week of Caroline's. Uh,
I want to thank everybody.
Got Two more shows.
I'm recording this a Sunday afternoon
before I do my final two shows.
As you notice,
my voice is a little froggy yet out
from screaming like a Jack Ass all week.
The problem is, is I have the sensation
opening up for me and you know,
the way he screams as a feature act,
I have to go there as a headliner
and I have to yell even more.
Um,
you know,
we've been having a real good time this
week giving each other shit about each
other's acts. The stuff we don't like
about it and both of our x got better.
You know, our friendships suffered
a little bit on a creative level,
but I think at the end of the day,
it's a nice thing.
I know what a lot of
you guys are thinking,
well why didn't you just have Joe come
over and do the fucking podcast? Ah,
because we drank until five in
the morning. That's why. Okay.
I just thought of a common courtesy.
You know, friend of friend,
when you drink with somebody
till five in the morning,
you don't ask them to drag their ass
out of bed and come in onto your podcast
for absolutely no fucking money.
Do you know what I mean?
Although I bet if I put a couple of
eclairs down, I bet Joe would show up.
You know? Oh, fucking
shoeless Joe. All right.
What else? Fucking Goddamn jets. One.
I don't have a TV so I have no
fucking idea. I didn't watch it.
It looks like the dolphins blew that one.
So they had their two in one.
I figured by the time you hear this,
the Patriots will be one and two.
I don't know how the Patriots are
going to be one of those teams.
You know that those jerk offs on ESPN
will be like, you know, I'll tell you,
I thought of Patriots. They're like
gotta be thick and which teams good.
We'll be showing up some borrow Alene
we'll give the steps first week.
I'll bleed. Who score like 48 it will
it move to d and you think it will cook?
Shut up. You fucking nerd. You know,
you know what I want.
I want well spoken people who actually
played the game to tell me what I should
be thinking.
I don't want to listen to somebody
who went to fucking journalism school.
All right. And was in chess
club telling me what, what,
what Tom Brady's got to be
thinking, you know what I mean? Oh,
I'm fucking grumpy. Um, I don't
even know what's going on.
I went to a fucking football game
last week, so I missed the Patriots,
blow it against Tampa Bay.
I still have that on my DVR.
Okay.
You liked that echo in this apartment,
in these sparsely
furnished apartment I have.
You know what's great about an echo in a
Roman makes it just makes you feel like
you're addressing a bunch of people.
Af
what's your country?
You know,
I think I could get one of those political
speeches, one of those raw, raw thanks.
Okay.
Today America,
is that across drugs
and if you look back at our
history in this country,
is that the fly by the choices that
we make? Would we have to cross drugs?
Thanks Frank. Makes
Carriage. Thanks. Conviction.
Well,
I believe,
am I fell out if he's just sitting
there staring at their shoes,
waiting for that fucking moment where
they know this supposed to clap.
Did I feel that we can rise
above today's challenges?
Because that's what American late,
Huh?
But nobody starts fucking clapping and
then you sit and they're gone. All right.
That's good. That's good. I got
through the first 10% of the speech.
Nobody's taking a shot at me,
so I haven't pissed off the loonie birds
or the people who employ me. Right.
I haven't pissed off the bankers of
the corporations and I even pissed off
fucking Eddie Earl fucking
Johnson from east Mississippi,
which coming up here with
his handmade fucking glock.
Is that what rednecks do not,
they just sit around all a widow,
[inaudible] widow and all day,
you know what their fucking weapons,
you know something guns or
like the comic book for like a,
for like rednecks.
You're like nerds always into like they
have like a comic book collection like
Anthony Cool.
Mia from the wonderful ONA program.
He's like a comic book nerd except he's,
he's into guns and instead of talking
about whether the whole could be captain
America, he talks about, oh, the
lovely Nia. Everybody hang on.
Hey Nia. Hey, I'm almost done recording
the podcast. Let me call you right back.
Bye Bye. See that? That was a
little white lie. Not almost done.
I'm only fucking 10 minutes
then that's what you gotta do.
That's what you gotta do to keep
a relationship going. You know,
you don't tell big lies,
but a bunch of little ones
going to be there in five minutes.
How many times you tell that way,
Huh? Absolutely. Yes.
I was listening to you
while you were talking about how your mom,
I don't know why you fucking coming at
me, right? We've all done that shit.
You know I did this morning. There's
so much of a fucking sports nerd. I am.
I just wrote down all the
fucking teams that I've seen.
People seem to be interested
in that. Well, who's kid?
Who's kidding? Who Others?
Fucking sports nerds. Um,
what the hell is it here?
I only need to see for more professional
teams. 14 more and I'm done.
I've seen all the fucking baseball teams.
I've seen all but five,
right?
All but football teams and I'm going to
see three of them in the next fucking
month or so. So I'll have
one more. Their hockey.
I got three more to see Ottawa.
The hurricanes in the
lightening otherwise known is,
Oh gee. And judge, who the fuck wants
to go to any of those places? Ottawa.
Huh? You're halfway to Toronto. Um,
the hurricanes and the lightening get
assist. That's just not going to happen.
And then basketball,
I got the dirty south.
I don't know when the fucking want to see,
have the grizzlies,
the bobcat's the fucking magic.
I never go down south, right? The Hornets
at the Spurs and the sons
and then the raptors. Really,
I'm going to go all the way to
Toronto to go see a fucking CBA team.
These last few are going to be rough.
They're going to be rough. And, um,
I wonder what's going to happen
when I finally complete this goal.
Am I going to have the high five myself
for going to all these events by myself?
Isn't it rather sad when you
think about it? Even nerds,
when they go to the fucking comic cons,
they got someone to go with, right?
Drive next week, sit next to each other
as they drive down to the fucking thing.
Um, all right, let's do a little
advertising. Shall We? People,
some starting to fucking sweat
here had opened a window.
I hope I'm not being too Goddamn
loud. What are you going to do? Huh?
Yell at me. Hey, fucking keep it down.
Yeah, you fucking keep it down. Um,
stamps.com everybody.
Would you like to bring the post office
into your apartment, into your house,
into your dwelling? Wouldn't that
be great? Who's kidding? Who?
Go on to the post office. Sure.
You see other people, you know,
you listen to that dumb stories about
what their kid's doing. You don't care.
You don't care about that kid. You
probably think that Kit's ugly, right?
Why do you want to go down
and listen to that dumps?
Stories run into that person
who was sitting there. You know,
you haven't seen him since high school.
Why wouldn't it be great if you could just
stay in your own place where you live?
Just print out your own steps. What if
you got a little scale? You could, oh,
I want to put some in a box. He is
way it, right? He bought a little,
a little stamp on it.
You take it out to the post office and
you tell that psycho to pick the damn
thing up and take it back
to the place where he works.
Then you'd done when that be awesome.
Well listen,
you could do that with stamps.com.
You can buy and print us
official US postage using
your own computer and printer.
You can get the postage for any letter
or package whenever you need it. 24,
seven you can do it at
four in the morning.
You can do it 11 o'clock and then
just hand it over to your mail man.
Just like I said, and you'll never have
to go to the post office again. Okay,
that's it. Um, it's great
for small business homes,
offices and people like me that you
stamps.com to send out DVDs to my fans.
Provided there's some available
whole different story.
It saves me time, money and makes my life
easier. Uh, right now use my last name.
Burpee.
You are are for this special offer,
a no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer
that includes a digital scale and up to
$55 free postage. Don't wait. Go to
stamps.com before you do anything else,
put down that eclair.
Click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in Burb,
B u r r a.
That's bird
[inaudible] dot com. Sorry, I just got
distracted by the phone. So anyways,
back to the Goddamn podcasts here.
Sorry.
I actually had to take
that fucking phone call,
but through the wonder
of the pause button. Um,
I can't wait to get the fuck out of New
York. I got to tell you something. This,
I can't see.
Stay in shape in this fucking city,
especially when you're going out,
God damn drinking and then you fucking
walk home when you get the slice of pizza
or a fucking Goddamn Bacon,
egg and cheese. You know,
it's amazing that everybody in this
city doesn't weigh nine zillion pounds.
I guess it cause you walk around
so much, you know, I dunno.
I have to give a shout out to the,
uh,
sort of like dictate or light that they
have here. Um, what's his name? Bloomberg.
You know that guy,
you know who are legally you can only
have two terms and somehow he got around
it and he's in his fucking third
term. Basically. He's going to leave.
He's going to step down being mayor when
he's God damn ready. This motherfucker,
he's taken away. He puts seats in the
middle of the street and Times Square.
He did it down there. Macy's, the
old Herald Square. All right man.
I came right right back.
Huh? Ah, AH, right.
Harold Square and a and then I'll
know all these other fucking streets.
He just lets people kind of park did
in the second lane over from the curb.
And then the other lane is like a,
a bike lane.
I guess he just doesn't want
people driving around anymore.
Either that or he's aware that the world
population is going to be reduced by
90% and he's getting the
jump just going like,
well we don't need all
these fucking leads.
You don't need all this shit. You
know, we'll just put some seats.
We'll put some sun chairs right in
the middle of fucking times square.
Maybe you know something. Maybe
he's trying to warn us, you know,
but if he warns us,
they're going to kill his entire family.
So these are the little hints that
he's giving us these little things.
He used his fucking money to stay in
office, to give us the hint that the, uh,
the extermination is
coming, right. See, this is,
this is why I need is so good for me and
having a dog when I'm around people and
I, you know, you just have,
you have great thoughts.
This is how you become the Unabomber.
You just fucking hang out with yourself.
It only takes a good eight days,
eight days just slowly go nuts.
You start,
you just start thinking about a,
I don't know why you think about
how you'd think about dying.
Okay?
Thinking about that shit. This is just,
this is fucking depressing. You know,
it'd be great if I watched some football.
I could talk about that.
I have absolutely nothing to talk about.
I can just riff about the fucking bare
walls in my fucking apartment here.
Would you guys be upset with me if I just
broke down and started crying here on
the podcast?
Would you do that?
Oh,
here's something for you made you came
by with some of the cities I'm going to
be performing in next
year. Next year, baby.
Would you like to hear him?
Would you like a list of some of them?
I got and let me see. Let me see
if there's some here that I've, uh,
haven't been to in awhile.
Why do we got here? Oh No,
I've been all of these fucking cities.
Oh,
I'm finally maybe going to have
a Vegas night. That'll be great.
Why don't you guys come out and see me
in Vegas? Come out there with your boys.
Get drunk, get a fucking whore. Right?
Couple of call girls
luck. Be a lady two
nights. Put on a condom.
That's right.
And even afterwards you jump in the
shower and wash your crutch real good.
You should've just had her
blow Ya. Ah, you fucking nuts.
Why'd you go inside?
Who fucking knows what's
in that fucking coach. See,
this is why I have to close
the window so I can't do this.
People have kids in this building.
All right.
I'll tell you this.
Water is Poland.
Spring water that was probably bottled
nine years ago and put in a warehouse is
absolutely fucking delicious.
How do they keep the algae off of it?
Do you know my, I have a fucking, um,
I have a water fountain and my front yard
and I know what you're thinking. Jesus,
your house must be amazing. It isn't.
And neither is the water fountain.
It's this little douchey.
It's like,
it's like somewhere between like
a fucking bird bath and something.
Jesus would wash his, you know,
wash maybe your feeding. Right.
He wouldn't wash his feet because that
would actually be doing something for
himself, which he never did. He
never did anything for himself.
He did it all for you. And thanks
a lot for not appreciating them.
If you turn your pages, oh, I
was going to go to church today.
Okay.
I was actually going to do
that. Why don't I go? Cause I,
cause I didn't get up Til fucking 12,
like doing that every once in a while,
just going,
going down there and remembering,
then I'm going to go to
some fiery fucking grave.
MMM.
So anyways,
so I got this little stupid glorified
bird bath if they call in a fountain.
And uh, I, I just feel like for
me, I can't keep the thing clean,
which just algae all
over the fucking place.
He's got damn mosquitoes
laying eggs in there.
So then I got to go out and go buy all
this fucking poison and stick it in the
water.
Okay.
You know, and then what happened since
some other animal comes by and goes,
Oh wow,
look at the god damn water.
I think I'll have a drink and then I
fucking whacked this skunk or a raccoon or
some other vomit.
You know,
technically those things are
vomit. I know. Yeah. What's
his face you sending me?
Sam gave that gave that word a bad name.
Well she is a rabbit. Considered a vomit.
Maybe it is. I was just told, you
know, if he had hair, you are a mammal.
I didn't know what farming is.
Farming like a racial slur for a mammal.
Okay.
Does that word mean midget in their world?
Cause I know like a skunk possum.
Okay.
What else does he have? Raccoon. Those
are all varmints like when you're,
when you're a redneck or a
serial killer, you know, that's,
that's what you start with except
rednecks for the most part.
They stop at like elk where if you're a,
you're a serial killer, you keep going.
But I don't think you work your way
up to elk. You know, I think you, you,
you kill like a,
uh,
like an adolescent bear and then you
kill a fat person and then that's
okay.
That's the off ramp you take.
Right.
Um, I am a fucking minutes. Am
I in, what am I talking about?
Oh Jesus. 22 fucking minutes in. Can
I, can I put out an RFP this week?
Is that good?
You know,
it'd be great if somebody has to fucking
question and Nia and then I could do
another one of those epilogues and then
I'll fucking splice it back on like raw
Maria attaching a limb.
Would that be phenomenal?
You can't believe the shit that
I watched this week on Youtube.
I watched some shit about some soldiers
coming back from Iraq talking about all
the horrible stuff they did.
Take them metals off,
throwing them and that type of shit.
And uh,
uh, and, and you know, I don't know,
just can't wrap my fucking head around.
It's too much, too much to take in. And
that's thing I needed to watch football.
I needed a little bread and circus SEL
expression goes right whenever the people
are ready to revolt against the king and
they sent out some bread and they sent
some tumblers down there and some people
to tell jokes and everybody got shit
faced at bellies were full of bread and
they're like, Eh, the kings are right.
Well we'll attack the castle tomorrow,
right.
Maybe sat down a couple of harlots.
Isn't that what they did or did it,
am I remembering like an episode
of like a game of Thrones?
I want to start watching that show.
I watched a couple episodes in that
little kid is just so fucking evil, man.
You know, it's like a whole nother
level, like a children of the corn,
that kid,
that little bastard.
Is there anything more hateable
then I'll kid in power. You know,
I wonder if they got whacked more
than an adult. I'm an adult GI.
You actually, you can eat at least think
that maybe they worked to get the job,
but you know when you sit in
there taking fucking, you know,
some eight year old kid with his head
is fucking voice hasn't even changed.
I have to learn how to
scream properly on stage.
Fucking voice gets like this
every guardian weekend. Wow.
Let's read some more fucking
advertising for Christ's sake.
At least I can get that in.
Right.
I'll get that in before this thing
slowly Peters out. You know, actually,
you know when you think about is it just
kind of a nice way to start the week?
I feel like,
you know what I feel I'm speaking in the
same voice like someone speaks and then
like the end of a yoga class.
I hope you guys all have a wonderful week
and just remember some of the lessons
that you've learned over the
last hour connecting, letting go,
getting in touch with that voice inside
you. I'm sorry. I know this is creepy.
All right. He voice everybody. Would
you like to turn your life around?
Would you like to start a business without
having to actually have a place where
it exists?
When that be awesome?
Wouldn't be great if you could act and
make it sound like you actually had an
office. Well, he voice
gives you that ability.
You don't have to buy another cell phone
because with the wonder of iie voice,
you can get a bunch of cell phone numbers
for your cell phone. And once again,
I forget what the word is. Why do I
always want to say viral phone numbers?
Why don't I write it down
on this copy virtual,
you can get bunch of
virtual phone numbers.
You can walk up to somebody with
the cell phone that has a number,
another number to it and say,
this is my business number. Okay.
And then they think that call in
an office because they also have a,
they have professional lab voiceover
actors for your answering machine.
They'll pick it up and make it
seem like you have some James Bond,
maybe partner or some sexy
coworker or something like that.
They get called forwarding toll free
1-800-NUMBERS. Um, automatic attendant,
advanced voicemail, voicemail,
the text voice mail, the email.
Uh, he voice is perfect for
business, for the business,
for a business person on the move.
Um,
click on the voice banner on
billboard.com podcast page.
You go to www dot e voice stars calm
slash bill burr to get your exclusive six
month free trial eve voice, your
mobile phone at work. I mean,
that's tremendous. It really is
tremendous. I wish they had that one.
I was starting now, but you
know, then again, I didn't
have an idea for a business.
I wish I could utilize that back
in the day when I wasn't smart.
What do you guys think about the
Patriots? Raven's tonight? You know,
what do you think?
What do you think?
I'm worried that Tom Brady
is going to get hurt tonight.
I gotta be honest with you. We got a
rookie protecting the fuck and blindside.
I don't like it. I don't like
it. We're good against the run,
but all they got to do
old Joe Flacco himself.
If he finally plays up to his potential,
all right.
They only got to do is just
go into the hurry up offense.
It's all they got to do when they get
to you got to go right down the goddamn
field. Um, all right,
let's read some fucking a,
let's read some questions for this week.
We're on the,
we're on this side of the half hour
and I'm already into the questions.
Can you believe that?
I know what you're not.
I know it was something that you can
absolutely believe is that I can't find
where the fuck the questions are in the
God damn podcast. Oh, there they are.
All right.
Oh,
he's a pet peeve of mine in New
York that I completely forgot about.
When you walk down the street, I'm
like, how fucking angry you can get,
you know when you walk in behind somebody
and you try and go past them cause
they're walking too slow and they
serpentine down the sidewalk.
It's like they're,
they're either doing it on purpose to
their fucking equilibrium is off and you
just want to punch him in the
back of every time you go left,
they start going life, he cut back. Right.
They need you to that fucking evil
exhale and they're fucking ear and it
startles him. You know, if it was a movie,
they drop a bag and a grapefruit
would roll out. So he's a great thing.
Great Visual and movies to let people
know that that character was startled
because they'd drop the bag of fruit.
Yeah. And it's always rollable fruit.
It's never a banana.
It would just fall.
They're like a fucking receiver
off a God damn phone. Um,
and then also how when you walking down
the street and a lovely ladies coming
your way and there's not enough room
for both. Yeah. You start to turn right,
you start to turn and she doesn't turn
it all like she's a goddess. You know,
it's just how far do I got to take
this gentlemanly thing? Why don't you,
how come I have to adjust my
body? 100%. You don't even,
they don't even fucking look at you.
They just like stare straight ahead.
You know what I used to do in New York?
I had this passive aggressive fucking
move that I would do. I had a, um,
you always have like a bag.
If you're going to be out for a while,
you know you don't have a car,
so you get all your shit
and like a fucking backpack.
I'd have it slung over one shoulder and
if somebody was not going to get out of
my fucking way as or more isn't even
making an attempt to adjust their body as
they were walking by me and I got
to do all the fucking moving, right.
Like this unhealthy fucking relationship.
What I do is right as they're
about ready to pass me,
I'd have my bag on my right
shoulder there on my left.
What I would do is write
as they go and buy me,
I would turn around and
look over my right shoulder,
turning my back and whacking them with
the bag and then I'd immediately turn
around, be like, oh, I'm sorry.
Sorry about that. You know,
totally fucking passive aggressive.
That's how,
that's how I handled that shit cause that
wasn't man enough to just punch him in
the face. Um, all right,
here's one from a lady.
Hey Bill,
what kind of Sunscreen do you use?
Um,
I unfortunately don't really use
sunscreen when I do use it. Uh,
I don't go higher than 50. If you
try to use, when I use the 100,
it's so thick.
It like pulls my arm hair off.
It feels like glue,
you know,
sunscreen. A hundred fields
like glue, but I'll use 50,
35 but the key is you got to wear a hat
because you can't put sunscreen above
your eyes cause it drips down
and he gets all stinky. You know,
I don't put it on my face too
much. I got, I got a B in a hat.
I think I'm all right. Um, I don't know.
Does that answer your question?
We just really saying you're a pasty
motherfucker. Nah, I know you use it.
Are you a fellow red head? Is that
what you are? I don't fucking know.
Um, a lady roommate. Hey
Bill, huge fan of the show.
Wanted to see if you had any
advice for this situation.
I found myself in a
little over a month ago.
I moved to Phoenix and moved
in with the friend of Iad.
You go up camelback mountain yet? That's
a fucking great hike. You got to go up.
That one.
Somebody dies up there every fucking year,
which always cracks me up to be
like alone in the wilderness.
While you can actually see
buildings in the distance,
that's gotta be so frustrating.
Um,
little ugly ass fucking road runners.
All right. A little over a month ago,
I moved to Phoenix and moved
in with a friend from college.
No real problems there,
but he did have a female college
age roommate that he got along with.
So we ended up setting settling
on a three bedroom. All right,
so it's two dudes and a chick.
She's already like a Sitcom.
This is like fucking
reverse three's company.
A Nunga models
will,
it gives us,
I remember I've fucking, America was just
like that, you know? Nice and simple.
I guess it was probably fucked up then.
I was just too young to notice
sitting there eating a popsicle.
Well look, is this, ah
Huh. Please go bloody dude.
You do. Boop. Larry's
upstairs. 50 years old.
Fucking everything that
moves. Um, all right.
I only know a few people in town
and my work schedule is grueling.
It makes it really hard to meet to too
many people over the course of the week.
All right,
so you're setting up your excuse for
why you're already fucking your friends
friend. All right. You know, I work a
lot. I can't get to meet people. Uh,
why go out for pussy when it's right next
door? I get it buddy. I get it. You know,
it's discovery channel.
Does the line go after the toughest zebra?
The fucking wounded one of
the little baby one. My,
the one walking around wearing
the fucking juicy shorts. Um,
I'm sure by now you've pinpointed the
key word in the above paragraph. Female.
Yes I have sir. Yes, I have. So
he can see where this is going.
My second weekend here,
we all go out get sloppy jalopy drunk
and she informs me that she broke up with
their boyfriend of five
years. Oh, wonderful.
So of course I do the gentlemanly
thing and fuck your brains out.
Oh, he goes, so of course, yeah,
I do the gentleman thing and fuck her
brains out or flop around like a dead fish
on top of her. Um, it's one of
too, once I'm done, I leave,
I go to my room and we don't mention and
we don't mention you don't mention it
in the morning and it's
not awkward at all. Ah,
if I had the Allah your song,
Oh, that's fucking great.
Would you guys look down at me if I
told you that I was just jealous of this
person right now?
That's fucking perfect.
And the hardest thing is going to be for
you to not fuck this up for you not to
develop failing's.
Okay.
Yeah.
You know, that's going to be a hard
one. But if you could somehow do it,
if you could somehow keep
yourself separated, you know,
you could just, Eh, it would be like a,
it'd be like stamps.com having the
post office and you fucking apartment.
Now you've got the post up your apartment
and now you have this blow job machine
also there. I mean it's
just tremendous, you know,
and then all you gotta
do is just decide what,
what kind of food you're always
going out for and you really like,
and you buy that appliance speed, a Panini
maker or a fucking cappuccino maker.
You got that stamps.com and the blowjob
machine down the hall and I tell you
that's it. Get the NFL
package, call it a life.
Um, so anyways, he goes, well,
we've gone about doing
this for a few weeks now,
but since I'm never home during the
week and she works during the day on
weekends, we don't exactly see
each other. And when we do, we,
we literally never say anything about
it or hint added at all, et Cetera.
Don't please don't fuck this up.
Please don't fuck this up. Okay? He says,
my question being as this is the first
time something like this has happened,
is this a time bomb waiting to happen?
We're all the crazy is going to come
flying out like the Ark of the covenant or
she just rebounding.
And I'm the free and clear until I
settle in and find something else.
Keep in mind, keep in mind that Jesus
cries. Sorry, I didn't go to church today.
Has died for rose and
is risen from the grave.
He did it all for you.
There's no way for you to thank him
once you give us a bunch of money.
Um,
keep in mind I've never been accused of
being good looking and she's pretty cute
with the grade a ass on her.
Any advice is appreciated and
I guess go fuck yourself. Um,
okay. All right. You did
the right thing. You know,
you've got a great situation and
you don't want to fuck it up.
Okay?
You know,
this is like the first time I went
deep sea fishing and I got a bite and I
looked at the dude next to me,
my doing it right. What do I do?
And I got to let it run a little bit.
Let it run a little bit.
Ne bringing it right.
You're doing the same thing all.
So what is your question here?
Is this a time what this is?
Okay. There's, there's the wildcard
that she's a psycho, but she, she,
she would have shown her colors by now.
I would think if she was a psycho,
you know, there would have been some
sort of, you know, God, you work so much,
I don't get to see you or
you would have to do on that,
you know, fucking twisting your arm hair
or doing something fucking annoying.
Some sort of annoying sort of touching.
Right. So she hasn't done that.
She's totally putting out the vibe
that
she's basically in the mindset.
It's this thing seems like it's
exactly what it is. You know,
she was in a relationship for
five years, five years, man.
She's got to decompress from that.
All right.
She likes to go out and get hammered and
get fucked and go to bed and not see a
dumb ass for the whole. All right.
Just keep it at that. This is the deal.
You don't have to bring it up either.
You don't have a bring it up either.
Just keep it the way it is. All
right. If she's barely talking to you,
you barely talked to her and he just have
fun with it and this is another thing
you do. All right. Have
Fun with this shit.
What is some things that you always wanted
to do with the woman and you haven't
done yet? This is the girl
you do it with. All right,
and she's going to probably do it with
youtube because she doesn't give a fuck
about you, which is a great thing.
What you have, sir is a fuck buddy.
Congratulations. This is your first
one. This is what men dream of.
This is what men really want. This is
what we want for Christmas. You know?
If we could just have a fuck buddy,
somebody who was clean with no diseases,
you know,
and somehow then had this pill they
could give you that you drank, you know,
you're washed it down and it got
rid of any sort of fucking guilt.
It will be perfect.
But just single dudes so there's no guilt.
So my thing is just don't, don't open
your mouth and fuck this thing up.
All right? You got a great thing going.
Okay. Just keep doing what you're doing.
And uh, the only thing I would correct
is this whole thing where you say,
you know, I'm not that good looking a
guy, you know, work on your self esteem.
She's pretty cute. Hey, you know,
good for her. She's got a nice ass.
Why don't you go fucking do some to it,
but not during the week.
No fucking during the week you focus on
your job, you have a great fucking time.
And I know it,
you know,
I guess eventually if you do meet somebody
and you start bringing them around,
there's, there is a potential, but uh,
you just got to nip that shit in the,
but I guess you've actually
met somebody that you liked,
uh,
at Jesus and he says, yeah,
I didn't think about that.
All right. First, first things first
before we even get over to her.
Uh, I mean, does it okay. Whole
new can of worms here, dude.
You have to be cool first and foremost.
All right. Because eventually,
you know,
if she meets some other dude,
you got to make sure that
you're not going to flip out.
So do not develop any
feelings for this girl.
And the only way you're not going to
develop any feelings for this girl is if
you see her once a fucking
week and your Banger, okay?
You don't want to know how many
brothers and sisters she has, right?
It's like reservoir dogs. You guys
shouldn't even know each other's names.
Tell me your name though to be a fucking,
I don't want any name. Yeah, you don't.
You don't. You want that? All right. All
right. You fucking Mr Pink or whatever.
She's missed a blonde or
Mrs Blonde. Uh, sorry.
Um, that's the only thing
you got to worry about.
All right.
So,
and I've learned to just be totally
fucking up front and honest self.
I got some new girlfriend. I would just
tell her what's up. So what's your deal?
Yeah, I'm single. I'm kind of banging my
fucking roommate once a week, you know,
we don't, you know, it's just
sort of a fuck buddy. Think. Oh,
does that make you
uncomfortable? Well, all right,
well then this relationship isn't
going to work because you're already
uncomfortable with me.
Now if I got feelings for you,
I wouldn't keep banging her,
but you know,
I'm not taking it off the table
after one fucking trip to Applebee's,
Jesus Christ free pussy. That's
like free shoes for you, right?
You know, I dunno. That's all I all I can
tell you, dude, you can't control her.
Who gives a fuck?
Dude?
Some day you're going to be 50 and you
gotta be married and she's going to be
bitching at you about something needy.
If you love her,
you at some point you just
can be reminiscent going,
you know when my life was the greatest
was when I had that little fucking
goddamn three bedroom apartment.
All I had to do was make this amount of
money a week and I had some chick once a
week with just fuck my brains out and
not talk to me for the other six days.
Goddamn dream. You got to dream, sir.
All right, and I don't know where,
but enjoy it while it lasts.
Okay.
I hope I answered your question. I really
do. You're in a hell of a situation.
Enjoy it. All right. Kudos
to you. I am jealous.
All right. Never by the largest
bottle of fucking water.
You bring it back down at
splashes in your face. All right,
next one here.
You know,
I was actually just thinking about
that whole new world order thing.
The new world order.
Say they say they're going to get the
population down to fucking 90% I know you
guys are flipping out.
How do you even do that?
Dino does the whole world,
just all,
somehow the world leaders
all finally agree. All right,
we're all doing the same thing.
Starting,
we're all going to kill
90% of our citizens.
Like how would you even begin?
How would you even begin that endeavor?
Okay,
well we just knocking
door to door. Hey, guess,
guess who's not on the right
list? Come on, pack up your stuff.
Oh, who gives a shit? Alright,
plowing ahead here. Um,
dad's getting a little too comfortable.
Hey Bill.
My brother and I live in our father's
house and recently he decided it's okay to
walk around the house and nothing
but sweatpants when he comes home.
He's gotten pretty fat over
the last couple of months
and it's pretty disgusting
to see. Is a euro giggly, you mean?
Gigli hairy stomach and tits around
while I'm trying to watch TV or work at
home. He also tells me what to do even
though he's kind of a piece of shit.
Uh,
he's a ta easy type that would get mad
if you confronted him and start wearing
almost nothing at all.
Okay.
Um, oh, nothing all the
time or worse somehow.
What should I do?
Okay.
Um, well, I don't know. Write a
song called Dad. Put your shirt on.
I don't fucking know. First of
all, you don't, you gotta do,
you got to get over yo this,
this whole, this whole fucking
okay.
Fear of confronting your dad.
You just got to get over it.
Just confront the guy and if he
starts walking around in his bbds,
you guys just sit around you
and your brother, your sister,
he just ridiculed them. Just
start chanting Tba Shit,
Todd by shit. Something.
I don't know what to tell you. You
know, why don't you just say Ya.
Ah,
how would you do it?
Maybe just act like you're giving them
a compliment when you're insulting him.
Okay.
Wait, just comes walking in.
Just be like, Hey, nice tits.
Okay.
And then as he goes to fucking respond,
you do,
you just sing that song that
doesn't exist yet. Eight day. Ah,
you just fucking walk away
and don't listen to him.
Yeah.
That's got to be the greatest
set of Harry tits I've seen. Bup,
bup, bup, bup. Booboo. You know,
just start making songs up.
Oh, theory is, oh, thank God. You know.
Thank God I was worrying that I wasn't
going to get to see you half naked today.
This is awesome tech.
Could you do me a favor?
I know you've done so many
wonderful things to me.
Is there any way you could get fatter?
You know,
could I buy some Rogaine
and just, you know, have you
sprinkle it on your fucking,
just so you can be even more sweating and
Harrigan fat. Could you do that for me?
Dead. That's awesome. You know,
do you have any consideration
for mom whatsoever?
She must have been attracted to you
at some point, right? Are you so fat?
You can't even wear a hoodie.
Just just to just roast the guy.
Okay.
All right. Here we go. Let's
just fucking plow ahead here.
Yeah, why don't you do that, right? Some
old school jokes, although she had ted,
so you get fucking beat, but
not, but do we just fill it in?
I'm turning old friend into
girlfriend. All right. Wait a minute.
I already read that one. Oh, this
is a new one. All right, Bill.
Loved the podcast would really
like yours and knee as if possible.
Thoughts on the subject. Oh,
you want Nia? She's not here. I,
it might be time for another
little fucking MMP epilogue.
I'll see if she's up for it.
I'm only in town for a day and a half.
I don't know if I have to. You
know what? I'll do another one.
You guys liked the last one so much.
All right. Here we go. There's a girl,
there's a girl. I know where the
hipsters go called cunty but dude,
twist, twist. Um,
I should really hand out a free
DVD for everybody knows that song,
but I won't because there's too
many Flintstone fans out there.
That was the bed rock song.
Um,
there's a girl I'd been friends
with for over a decade now.
We met in college and for
about a year or two back then,
I would have considered her
one of my closest friends here.
We start reading and you're just not
even listening to what you're saying.
You guys mind if I go back, is
this a guy? What are we doing here?
Um, there's a girl I'd been
friends with for over a decade now.
We've met in college and for about
a year or two back then I would have
considered her one of my closest friends.
Um,
during that whole time
she had a boyfriend.
So I never thought about making a move
and lack the confidence to do so anyway.
As time went on,
we gradually lost contact until
recently when I found her on Facebook.
Well how did you do that until recently
when you searched her on Facebook?
Cause you would thinking about
her if he just said that,
that would have been so much less creepier
than to say who until recently what I
found her on Facebook. Oh
Hey, you kind of did say that.
Am I even listening to what I'm saying?
I'm sorry sir. I'm an asshole. Anyways,
plowing ahead and we spoke for
the first time in eight years.
We live in the same city, so I suggested
we get together and catch up. Um,
which she is enthusiastic
about and is going in,
is going to happen sometime soon.
Now for the details.
We are both single and 30 years old.
She is recently divorced.
No kids clean break with little
or to no drama. She's beautiful.
And honestly one of the nicest people
I've ever met back when we were close I
was okay looking but
extremely skinny and shy.
Since then I put on about 25 to 30 pounds
of fat and muscle distributed pretty
evenly. I like this guy, he's honest.
Uh, so I'm looking much better.
Um, and that has boosted
my confidence, my question.
She is only know me as the friend zone
guy but does eight years with no count a
racist? Yes. Um,
and do you think I might
have a shot with her? Yes.
And any advice about how to go about and
how to act and what to say on the night
we catch up would be greatly
appreciated. Thanks in advance. GS.
One thing may be an issue here.
She doesn't have herpes does she?
Um,
after I suggested a ketchup,
I checked out her Facebook page and
it turns out that she changed her,
set their status from married to
single only a day or two earlier,
but in real life, she said she'd
been single for a few months.
So that was inadvertent,
rotten timing on my part.
Hopefully I don't come across as tankless,
opportunistic douchebag.
No, dude, you're fucking
overthinking that.
Unless she was sitting there
watching her Facebook page every day,
like a fucking day trader waiting
for her to get through that divorce,
then it would be creepy. But other
than that, no. Dude, you're a good guy.
Sounded good guy. Anyways. All right, so
what is your question? Okay, yeah. Dude,
you're not in the friend
zone anymore. You're a whole
new guy. Okay. You like the,
uh, you, you know, it's like, yeah,
yeah. To make over. He got some fucking,
he got a little brown going and
you got some confidence. Um,
you definitely have a shot with her. She
probably was Dayton asshole's back then.
And when she's going through that shit,
she was probably thinking,
you know,
at this time around I'm
going to get a nice guy, you
know, I should have got with,
he was just the nicest guy and for
some reason I just never fucking blah,
blah blah.
And we were such good friends.
She probably had that conversation and
when she got to the part where she said,
and we were such good friends,
she class both of her girlfriends
hands and her hands, you know,
and there's probably some crumpled up
tissues in her lap as like, you know,
she was getting through her divorce.
Oh look at me painting a picture.
I think you're in there. All right.
Now don't overthink this shit.
Okay.
Because you're acting like this girl's
already the one you don't fucking know.
You haven't seen her in eight years.
So just walk in there
fucking and have a good time.
Throw your Dick on the table and ask her
how she's been. What's up sweetheart?
The fucker you've been doing
for the last decade. Huh?
A couple more drinks over here.
Sorry.
Jokes into of the
podcast. Sorry people. Um,
okay.
Yeah, that's what I would do.
Or you're funny. Make a laugh.
I'd always works.
Okay.
Tell us she looks good. Just,
Oh, look at you. You look great.
Give her a nice hug or something.
You know, if she goes for the hug,
give her a hug.
Oh my God. That's the big thing. When you
walk in, do not fucking shake our hand.
Do not shake her hand. Don't go for
the hug. If you're not a good hugger,
but do not shake her hand.
Oh, if you're not a hugger,
then what the fuck are you going to do?
You gotta Hogrefe this is what you do.
You fucking act like Deniro in Goodfellas
after the lift one's a heist or
whatever the fuck it was. [inaudible]
Yo, come here, Yo God damn.
You got to have that fucking vibe.
Come make Yo. That's what you do.
What's the matter with you? Um, yeah,
just have her bring it in.
You're a nice fucking hug and you have a
couple of drinks. You know what I mean?
Let's see what happens. Just
don't, don't overthink it.
You're gonna end up psyching yourself up.
That's the only thing.
What the hell else did I want
to talk about? Oh, this week,
everybody this week. Oh,
Billy red face.
He's winding up in New York and then
I'm going down to Jacksonville, Florida,
Jacksonville, Florida. Everybody going
to go down there and watch the people,
rest of some gators. Um, I've
actually never been there.
Only thing I know about Jacksonville
is they have the Jaguars,
which I'm going to the game on Sunday.
And then they also have a Florida
plays Georgia there every year.
The biggest cocktail party in the
universities say stadium holds like 60,000
people in like fucking 800,000
people show up just to tailgate.
I imagine they make most of their
fucking money for the year. Um,
sounds pretty awesome.
So some of these already reached out,
said they'd take me shooting. I
want to go skeet shooting. You know,
I want to do something like that. I want
to do something fucking real. Goddamn.
Rednecky I went to fucking the
drag strip last week. Why not?
You're in Jacksonville when? In Rome.
Um, so I'll be at the comedy zone.
Tickets are going fast. Everybody,
believe it or not, never been there.
They're going fast. Maybe the yell at me
for calling, making fun of this city. Um,
and then the week after that
I go to Cincinnati baby.
If you ever wondered,
I wonder what ever became of me.
I'm telling jokes and a fucking mall,
a fucking strip mall in Cincinnati.
Um,
and then what do I go after that?
Then I come back to New York and
then I go to Australia to play the,
uh, the Opera House. You
know when they show up,
whenever they show pictures of
Sydney and they got that little,
a little clam shell thing,
they get a little club in there,
like a 400 seater and I'm
doing a, I'm doing three,
three nights there, I believe.
And then I'm doing some big
comedy festival out there.
I'm really excited about it.
And then I'm gonna stay for an extra
couple of days and believe it or not,
I think I'm going to go snorkeling
in the Great Barrier Reef.
Why wouldn't you? Because you
don't want to get eaten by a shark.
That's my big thing. I go, I don't
want to get eaten by a fucking shark.
A great white shark is what?
And the guy,
oh know that water's too hot
for great whites. Oh good.
So the other thousand species of sharks,
those are the only ones that got
to worry about hammerheads, tigers.
They got Barracuda out there.
First of all I want to do is take the
boat out and look at, and I'm like, no,
you gotta stick your faith in
the water and see all the colors.
So I'm going to do it. I'm gonna
roll the dice. You know why?
Because people do it every
fucking day and they don't die.
Every once in a while somebody dies.
So,
so why not you bill? That's what I
always come back to. Oh, gives a shit.
What would you rather do?
Would you rather be in an underwater
die in an underwater like wonderland
getting ripped to shreds
by some monster or a
die slowly in a FEMA camp smell and other
people's feet? I mean it's, it's just,
it's just no good way to go unless
you go when you sleep, you know,
with headphones on listening to the
Lake parade music will not be nice.
Um, all right. What do we got here?
Overrated. Underrated for this week, Bill.
Huge Fan.
First off,
get the fuck back to Melbourne again.
What's with this Cindy? Sydney bullshit.
Uh, Sydney only bullshit. Well,
I've never performed or I guess
I did Melbourne at one time,
but that was a comedy central thing.
Anyways,
I have a couple of hundred
raids for you. First. Uh,
first underrated rapping over heavy guitar
riffs and rap songs with Guitar Solos
in them. Why the hell isn't
anyone doing this anymore?
While I was listening to some old run
DMC songs like raising hell and tougher
than leather and that shit is the tits.
Secondly,
underrated Patrice O'Neil.
Sadly,
I never saw any of his
stuff until he passed.
Fucking shattered about that card is
elephant in the room special and it's
fucking epic. Clearly one of the best.
We'll be buying his entire catalog asap.
Well that's awesome man. Um, yeah, he was,
he was just getting
known by the massive sea,
but he was not underrated with fellow
comedians. Believe me. Believe me.
Um, so yeah, if you buy 'em,
if you by Mr p, all the proceeds
goes to a, goes to his mom.
So that's a cool thing to do. And
uh, yeah man, he, he's unreal.
I still can't talk about
that shit. Anyways, plowing,
he had the Monday morning podcast. This
is what it's banned people 55 minutes,
55 minutes.
That's what you get in this week as
they sit in my God damn hot apartment.
But you know something,
you're going to get the epilogue when
Nia answers whatever the hell that
question wasn't. Want to thank all you
guys for listening and uh, and seriously,
no bullshit.
Not Joking here.
I want to thank everybody for
coming out to these shows. You know,
I had eight shows here in Caroline's
and they've all been packed.
I went to two cities that
I've, you know, Orlando,
I never performed in the
old packed all weekend.
Charlotte was all packed and I'm hearing
that Jacksonville and Cincinnati is,
uh, is, is looking like it's going to
be the same thing. So, uh, you know,
just fucking unreal. It's
unreal. You know what I mean?
It's one of those deals where
every time you go into the club,
you PK hit your head in going like,
is this the show where it all
starts going back the other way?
And you see it's all the way to the back.
You're like,
thank God fooled them for another
day. Um, so I was seriously,
I want to thank everybody
who's come out and, uh,
I'm feeling great about my new hour.
I'm actually going to be taping
something for comedy central.
I'm doing that night
night of too many things.
Stars.
I know that is the worst name ever.
There's just too many stars. Was joking
with the Gao book me. I was like, okay.
They said if they said night of too many
Douche bags, I would have been all over.
But uh, I dunno. Ever Deli, it's
booked by this major guy in.
It's some guy that I should know and
it'd be a good thing if I did it for the
career. So you know, I got to do it.
I've got to jump on another
Goddamn plane right now.
I'm thinking about which bits, what
bit for my new hour am I going to burn?
I think I'm going to do the Steve
jobs bit. That's the game plan.
I'm going to do that one because I don't
think that that has enough legs until
my next special, it might, if I
can tag it on to something else,
I'm going to put it out there at the risk
of offending a bunch of fucking nerds
who were into technology.
I always think no matter
how fucking offensive I get,
the fact that you can just see through
to how fucking uninformed or stupid I am,
depending on how you read me
that that kind of, you know,
take some of the sting out of it.
Right.
Did I already begin the apology
for what the fuck I'm going to say?
I think I did. Alright, Dennis, a podcast.
You guys follow me on Twitter? No thing
that I said, I'd never do. I never tweet.
I actually, I'm Nia sent
me a clip of the, uh,
the official trailer for
the movie standup guys.
Do you remember back in April? I, I, um,
didn't do a podcast or I'm on a Monday
and it was really late and I said one day
I would tell you I would give you a
great excuse as opposed to all the other
weeks
when it's late,
just because I'm an idiot.
A one of those weeks I was
shooting those scenes in the,
and that movie stars a Alpa Chino,
Christopher Walken and Alan Arkin and I'm,
yeah.
So I was laughing when everyone's like,
where the fuck a podcast,
you fucking piece of shit. And
I so wanted to be like, well,
I had to do some scenes with some
of the greatest actors of all time.
Sorry, I'm late. You know, granted,
I only have a couple of words,
but it's big to me. Um, so
anyways, the, the official trailer,
if you're, if you're, um, do you
sign up for me on Twitter? Um,
you can see it or you can just go
on fucking youtube. Who's kid? No,
I'm just trying to get
more Twitter followers.
If you're already listening to this
shit that you need to be over there too.
You don't, it's redundant. It's like
I have your cell phone number now.
I'm asking for your home phone number.
You know what? Don't follow me on Twitter.
How about that? All right. That's the
podcast for this week. Go fuck yourselves.
Um, I'm really hoping my patriots are
going to win this week. I'm actually
watching the patriots in a different
way this year because I don't,
I don't think we're good enough.
I just don't think anybody in the AFC
is good enough to fuck with the NFC.
Although the 40 niners lost to the
vikings today. So who knows? Who knows?
Um,
but I'm just excited to watch,
hopefully the development of a,
a chat channel Jones.
I just hope he turns into a
first ballot hall of fame,
defensive absolute fucking nightmare for
the other team that just comes in and
just disrupts every pass play. Just
something that we, we've never had.
We've never had. The closest thing we
had to that was Andre tip it, you know,
and he was aligned back.
We've had some great linebackers,
Bruschi verbal and all those
guys. Willie McGinest, you know,
but we've never had a hall of fame.
I don't think we ever had
nick [inaudible]. He's
the only one we ever had.
We traded him to Miami because we thought
he was too small. And he was like,
I'll show you too small.
There's an undefeated season and two back
to back Superbowls. Go Fuck Yourself.
Thank you for the hall of fame
jacket. Um, all right, that's it.
I'll talk to you guys next week.
Go Fuck Yourself.